yes very exciting Rihanna shines bright
like a diamond dad warehouse her very
own diamond ball and reflects on the
10-year anniversary of her smash hit
umbrella I was happy with the number one
[Music]
ryona was bold in black at her annual
diamond ball for the clara lionel
foundation it's the same color she
rocked in the now iconic music video for
her 2007 global hit umbrella it's the
tenth anniversary of that video that
changed the game for you do what do you
remember from that time I remember the
UK blaming me for the rainiest summer in
history
JIT remember that they said every week
that it was number one they had rain and
I I couldn't take the blame I was happy
with the number one all that shining
Rihanna knows the importance of giving
back her annual diamond ball benefits
her Clara Lionel Foundation which
provides aid to communities in need
around the world are there to lend a
helping hand who are willing to do that
I think that's really important in our
community design the ball is so big and
people buy these really big expensive
tables to donate but my fans want to
feel like they're part of it as well and
maybe all they can offer is even $1 $1
so non-intimidating and I feel like
that's
it's working
you